- Hi, welcome everybody.
We are delighted to see all
of you attend this webinar
which is the second event
in the series of How to
Join the Quantum Workforce.
My name is, Florian Carle
I'm the Manager of the
Yale Quantum Institute
and I'll be one of the
moderators for this panel.
We are delighted to continue the series
which is organized jointly
by the Engineering Workforce Development
of the Center for Quantum
Network in Arizona
and the Yale Quantum
Institute in Connecticut.
So this is the second panel.
And today we are focusing on
How to Prepare for Grad School.
We wanted to offer this panel
since building quantum technology
requires a lot of people
with different backgrounds,
we need physicists, we
need electrical engineer,
we need computer scientists,
software engineer, chemists
and it can be really overwhelming
to consider a career
in quantum information.
So today we will hear from grad students
and grad school administrator and Dean
and what it's like to work in quantum
and get advice on how to
navigate the various pathway
to do a career in the
field of quantum science
and information.
I would like to introduce
my colleague Russell Balliet
who is the Assistant Director
of the Center for Quantum Network
and will serve as a co-moderator.
And so I will let him
introduce himself briefly
before we welcome our panelists.
- Yep, so thanks Florian.
So like said, I'm the Assistant Director
for Engineering Workforce Development
for the Center of Quantum Networks
so a lot of you are
already familiar with me
and I'm also managing a couple
of summer programs this year,
RUs and RUT.
So I'll be moderating as well.
And might chime in with my
graduate school stories.
Thanks Florian.
- So before we introduced
all the panelists today
some technical details for the panel.
So this event is recorded and
will be available on demand
on both of our institutes'
YouTube channels.
Only the panelists can talk
and so you are able to
ask all your questions
in the Q&A panel underneath
you have two speech toggle
if you click on it, you
can ask the question
and we will take this
question in priority.
And then since we cannot see you
we want to learn a
little bit more about you
so you should have on your screen
a poll that just pop in
so feel free to answer that
and that will allow us to
target our conversation
to have to answer most of the question
and see who's the audience today.
Okay, so moving on, let's
welcome our panelists.
You can turn on your webcams
and we're gonna start the introduction.
So let's start by let's do Emily
do you want to introduce yourself
so you can talk a little
bit about yourself
and why you wanted to go
into the quantum fields
and what it's like to be in grad school.
- Okay hi, I'm Emily Van Milligen.
I'm a fourth year graduate student
at the University of Arizona
where I'm currently
getting my PhD in physics.
I work in Saikat Guha's Quantum
Photonics Applications Group
he's actually in the Optics Department
which is nice because at the UoA
you're encouraged to work with professors
in different departments
than where you are in.
And I primarily focus
on studying the behavior
of quantum networks.
So I've been interested
in quantum mechanics
since I went to undergrad
at Tufts University.
And so I really enjoyed
my undergrad classes
and I just knew I wanted to take more.
I didn't really know if I loved research
or what I wanted to do,
I just knew that I wanted to
continue on to grad school
because I wanted to learn
more about the fields
and see what opportunities were out there.
And it was a really nice fit
going to the University of Arizona,
because at least in the physics department
they give you a couple
years to jump around groups
and find your actual fit.
So it's very flexible and it's nice
because as I was working
towards completing my masters,
taking my classes
I was getting to sample
all these different groups
and I found my home with Professor Saikat
and I really enjoy working with him.
I think it's fun because
the whole quantum world
like plays by a different set of rules
than like the world we interact
with on a day-to-day basis
and so that kind of just turns everything
into a giant puzzle for me.
So it's not really so much
work as it is like fun.
- Thank you.
Connor, do you want to go next?
- Sure.
Hi everyone.
My name is Connor Hann.
I am a, well, no longer a graduate student
at Yale University
I actually just defended my
thesis a couple of weeks ago.
So I just finished up
after five years at Yale.
I was advised there by
Professor Steve Girvin
and also co-advised by
Professor Liang Jang
at the University of Chicago.
So my journey into quantum
was perhaps a little bit more meandering
I definitely didn't know starting out,
even that I wanted to do physics
let alone quantum information.
When I started my undergraduate
at Duke University
I actually thought I wanted
to go be a medical doctor
but lo and behold there
were no spots available
in the first year bio class
and so I took physics instead
and then from there I realized
that that was the subject
I think I liked a lot more.
So I kept taking physics
courses and so on and so forth
until I found myself in quantum
mechanics in my junior year.
And once I'd taken quantum
it was really kind of
a no going back moment.
I sorta tried to shift
my research interests
in that direction and learn
more and more about the field.
But even by the time it came
to apply to graduate school
I had done some research
broadly in the field of quantum physics
but nothing with respect
to say quantum computing
or quantum information.
And so it really took
me even into grad school
to learn a whole lot
about the the field of quantum computing
where I now have done most of my research.
And I spent, you know, maybe a year or so
thinking about trying out
different groups at Yale
and figuring out what
would be a nice fit for me
but I was really happy ultimately
to wind up in the groups of
Steve Girvin and Liang Jang
because for me, one thing that
I really value in my research
is feeling a close connection
to practical applications
in the real world.
And so this is something I
felt with quantum computing.
You know, I could see the
tangible potential impacts
of the work I was doing on the day-to-day.
It felt more, you know
in touch with developing
technology and things like that.
So for me, that's always
been a nice aspect
of working in the field
and something that I've really enjoyed
and more broadly, yeah,
I've had a really fun time
studying quantum
it's been a really exciting
subject to pursue my PhD
and I'll be excited to continue
researching in the field
afterwards.
- Thanks a lot.
Ann, do you want to go next?
- Sure, my name is Ann Gaylin.
I'm an Associate Dean at Yale
and my portfolio contains a lot of things,
but I work with our graduate
programs on policies,
curriculum and annual reviews
for about 40 of our PhD programs.
I also work directly
with the faculty heads
of the graduate programs
what we call the Directors
of Graduate Study.
And I also work with some
of our graduate programs
on the admissions process.
So, first of all, I'm not
here to talk about quantum,
I know nothing about quantum,
so I will defer to the others
on the panel about that.
But I'm really here to
answer any general questions
you might have about graduate school.
And some of the things
you might want to ask me
about, what should I be thinking about
or preparing in order to
apply if I've decided to go?
Why might I want to go to graduate school?
What makes for a good application?
What should I know once I get here?
You know, how do you navigate
what some people call
"the hidden curriculum
of graduate school"?
And what kinds of
assistance either financial
or otherwise are available
in graduate school
to help me achieve my goals
and succeed in whatever
I've come to graduate school
to learn.
So I'll stop there
and look forward to
hearing your questions.
- Thank you.
So we can start by choosing the poll
and I can also share the results.
And we see that
everybody's very interested
in having like in STEM
careers, which is great for us.
However, we have like a
moderate understanding
on like the information on
the career so that's perfect
because we're gonna be able
to to help you figure out
if going to grad school
is the right move for you.
There's a turn off of way to
join the Quantum Workforce
and you can also see that all the panels
that we have in this series
we go from not only to grad school
to do a professorship
but also joining an
industry, joining a startup
and we also have alternative careers
so there's way more coming up.
So we're gonna start to
ask you a first question
and I think we're gonna ask
that to Emily and Connor
what it's like to work
in a in a research group?
So you joined to go to grad school
it started different than undergrads
because you don't really
join a school per se.
You don't have that, it's
not a curriculum of classes.
You have some classes
for the masters degree
but you also join a research group,
what it's like to work
in the research group
and how did you pick the groups?
And can you share your experience
on your day-to-day activities?
- I can go first.
So it's been a little strange for me
because when I joined the
group I'm currently in
like the next semester COVID hit
so a lot of it has been,
you know, remote over Zoom
just like this panel
but in a way it's been really cool.
So even though I haven't been able
to get to know everyone in my group,
because it is a large group
with like a lot of different interests.
I've gotten to know some people very well
who are studying similar things to me
but then I also get to
meet lots of professors
and students at other universities.
And so it's almost like
they're in my group
because we're all working
on the same stuff.
And so like a standard week for me
would be like working with
professors at like UMass Campus
so MIT and NAU
because it's the Center for
Quantum Networks is really great
where they really like
emphasize collaboration
so that's really interesting.
And so I enjoy getting to
work with these professors
and then other graduate students
and I even get to work with
undergrads, which is exciting.
And I think that as an
undergrad I was very intimidated
when I was working in a lab
I was like intimidated by my
superiors and now I realize
that like, we're all just like
on this pursuit to, you know,
further the field.
And like people are going to
respect my ideas just as much
and like I actually am contributing.
So that's exciting.
- Yeah, I can jump in
and say a couple of things
about my experience as well.
Maybe I should qualify what I'm gonna say
by pointing out that of course,
different research groups
are gonna have worrying
different kinds of environments.
So a lot of what your
experience is gonna be like
is gonna depend on the
professor you might choose
to work with and how that
professor runs their group
and what kind of atmosphere they foster.
So to say a little bit
about my own experience,
I'm a theorist so I don't
do any experiments myself.
I wouldn't be any good at it
but I like doing pen and paper
calculations and simulations.
And so what that means for me
and my research group on
the day to day is, you know
maybe about two thirds of
my time in any given day
is devoted mostly to my own work
either reading papers,
working out problems,
running simulations, this kind of thing
but, you know, there maybe
remaining one-third of every day
is usually collaborative work
either meetings or working out
problems with other people.
And it's probably that portion of the day
that I think is the most fun.
Those will be the times
when I'll chat with my research advisor
we'll try to brainstorm ways
to get around challenging
aspects of problems
or I'll work with other people in my group
and discuss topics that
we're all interested in
or attend seminars or do other things.
I think similar to Emily,
one of the really nice
aspects about being in a PhD
and getting to study interesting problems
is that oftentimes it really
is a very collaborative effort.
So not only do I have a number of people
within my own research group
that I'm working with at any given time
there are also other
people at other groups
within the university and
at other universities still.
So having a very nice and
collaborative research environment
has been a really valuable thing
that I've really appreciated
and one aspect of my research
group that I've really liked.
Another thing, I think Florian
you mentioned how, you know
people wind up choosing
different research advisors
one thing for me that
I think was really nice
as I shared with my potential advisors
I placed a premium on being able
to communicate effectively with my advisor
and really get a good sense for, you know
not only what they were interested in
but feel like we could have an easy
and free exchange of ideas
and that sort of thing
and that's been something really nice
that has helped me a lot in my PhD
feeling like I was always on
the same page as my advisor
we could work very well
and effectively together.
And so that's something
about my own particular
research environment
that I've really appreciated.
- Thank you both.
And to fill up on that the
other question in the chat
"what led you to choose
your respective grad school?
What was the sort of like, sort of hinted
at like how you picked your groups,
but like why the different school
and like what made you go to grad school?
- Well, for one reason it was
one of the places I got in-
- Its a very valid reason.
- But I would say that
like the best thing about,
like I think for me, like going
to the University of Arizona
was the flexibility I was
given at the beginning.
So I don't feel like I am behind
because I didn't go in knowing
which group I wanted to be in
and so that actually gave
me time to fill it out
and see who I thought
I would work well with.
So that was a really nice for me
but I do know others like
colleagues who kind of, you know
how to choose their group
before they went to grad school
and maybe then they've
realized that their advisors
are not everything they
were looking for in a mentor
but the nice thing is that
often even in those cases
I think that you can find someone else
like whether it be a
postdoc or like another,
because you're collaborating
with so many people
you can always find somebody
to help fill the needs that you have.
But I did like how going
to UoA gave me the time
to like, in-person fill out groups
and see what research I wanted to do.
- Yeah, and in my own case, I actually
I wound up applying to a large
number of graduate programs
because I was applying
together with my girlfriend,
now fiance.
And we wanted to try to
go to the same program
so we tried to maximize our chances
and apply in many places.
But, so I had a couple of
programs that I was looking at
and all of them
seem like they would have
great research opportunities,
cool things in quantum
so for me, a lot of the
decision between those programs
came down to some
non-academic factors too,
well, maybe first
I should say with regard
to the academic factors
one sort of prerequisite
that I used as a filter
to try and determine what
a good programs might be
is not only did I want to be
able to identify a advisor
at each of the potential
candidate programs
someone who I had talked to
and thought I could work well with,
I wanted to make sure there
was more than one such advisor
at each of these places
because you never know you
could go work someplace
and find out that, you know
that group isn't really
the way it appeared,
maybe it's not a good
fit for you after all
and you don't wanna be, you know
stuck out without a research group
where you feel like you
would be a good fit.
So having someplace
where it seems like
there are a lot of groups
that you could work nicely in
and see yourself thriving
and having a nice team time
and at least for me was an
important factor in my decision.
Another thing that in my case
was kind of a deciding factor
for Yale was I thought it
was a really nice environment
among the graduate students.
So in going and visiting the program
and getting to talk to the other students
everyone seemed by and large,
well, I should say physics grad school
can be a stressful time for sure,
but people seemed by and large happy
despite the stresses that are inevitable
in a graduate program.
And, you know, people
weren't massively overworked
they weren't working a hundred hour weeks
or anything crazy like this.
You know, it seemed like an environment
where not only did people
go and learn physics
and do exciting research
but they also enjoyed it
while they were doing it.
And there was a nice physics
graduate student community
that I wanted to be a part of.
So, you know, I guess
the takeaway from this
being that, you know, it's totally fine
and I think important to consider
also non-academic factors
when looking at a graduate program
thinking about the kind of
life you might have there
because of course, you know, five, six
or however many years it takes
to do a PhD is a long time
and you wanna think about
all the different things
that might contribute
to your quality of life
while you're there.
- Ann, do you want to
chime in on explaining
like how people can, like,
if you have general advice
on like how to bake your grad school,
like why they should choose
a certain grad school?
Like, what are the options for people
and why they should choose
certain grad school?
What are the criteria
that basically grad students would choose
or should look forward to?
- I think what you want to do
is first think about why you
wanna go to graduate school,
what do you want to accomplish?
Do you need a graduate degree?
As Connor said, graduate
school, it's a long time
five years for many degrees,
sometimes six if you
encounter some roadblocks
or something, you need to switch advisors.
So you really wanna make sure
that it's the thing for you.
And what do you want to learn?
Because what are the questions
that really excite you?
If, you know, quantum is interdisciplinary
so are there a number of
people or approaches to quantum
that you might want to be investigating?
I think Emily talked
about the fact that she's been
able to explore and, you know
especially if you're coming
straight out of undergrad
you may not be a hundred percent sure
of what about quantum is appealing.
And so a place where there
are a number of people
whose research looks interesting to you
is gonna be very important.
Another thing to be thinking about
is what do you hope to do
when you finish a degree?
And I'm not saying that to scare you
you shouldn't have your life planned out
but are you really interested
in pursuing research?
Are you thinking about
maybe teaching high school?
Are you thinking that you
want to go work in industry
and different kinds of careers
often require a different kind of training
and so if you're thinking
of, you know, I love physics,
I like the idea of quantum
but I'm really thinking
I wanna teach high school
you may not need to get a PhD
and a masters degree might be enough.
What about funding?
You know, do I have, am
I independently wealthy?
Most of us are not.
But graduate school, the nice
thing about most PhD programs
is you don't pay for them.
They pay you to study,
conduct research and teach.
And that's something that
some students don't know
that masters degrees
you usually have to pay for out
of pocket or take out loans.
But PhDs, usually if it's
a research institution
of some repute,
it's through a combination
of teaching and research
you won't be paying for your degree.
And so that's something
to be thinking about too.
And then, you know
I think the most important thing
is what kinds of questions
are the ones that you're
most interested in?
That'll help you
and your undergraduate advisors
should be able to help you
identify some programs
that might be a good fit
for your interests.
You'll want to look up some of the faculty
at the places you're thinking of
and see what their specializations are.
And I'm sure that Connor and
Emily can weigh in on this
that, you know, as Connor said
you don't wanna put all
your eggs in one basket
you wanna make sure that there's as...
because research interests do evolve
are there two or three people
you might be interested
in working with?
I see in the chat that there's a question
about "how do you reach out to advisors
at programs you're not yet
accepted in or involved in"?
And one place to start
would be the Director of Graduate Studies
or the Director of Graduate Admissions.
Every program has at least a
Director of Graduate Studies
some programs, because
they're large enough
have a Director of Graduate Admissions
and so you could say to them
I'm really interested in your program,
these are the things that are interesting
and I'd love to talk to
professor X or professor Y
or I'm really interested in X and Y
I'm not sure which of your faculty
are the ones that I might want to contact
but can you tell me about your program?
So that's one way to start that process.
If you've read something of
someone's or you have heard
or your undergraduate
advisor says to you, you know
given your interest,
you might be interested in
going to the university of X
and working with professor Y,
then you can just write an
email to professor Y and say
dear professor Y, my
undergraduate advisor,
I mean, I've been getting
a degree in physics
or computer science or engineering
and I'm interested in graduate school,
my advisor told me that your
research is very much in line
with the things I'm
interested in exploring.
Would you have some time to speak to me?
And now we can do that virtually,
if you're local, you
wanna try and go visit
so you could actually meet them.
I think Emily's point
about understanding the
community you're trying to join
is really important.
But you really wanna
be doing your homework
so that you can figure out
what are the places
that might be a good fit
for what you want to accomplish.
- And once you pick your grad school
I know that Yale has that
and I'm sure University
of Arizona has it too
there's something called
rotation or circulation
and so you pick a group for one
semester and sort of a trial
Connor and Emily, have you done this?
Have you taken the opportunity to do this?
And did you switch, did you
stay with the professor?
What were your experiences with that?
- Yeah, so I switched around
the first three semesters
at the UoA.
You can take independent
studies alongside your classes
and so like, that's common
is that you take two classes
and you're independent study
up until you have like your masters
and that independent study
will just be you working
with a different group.
And here it was nice
because you're getting funded
through your TA-ing initially.
So if you are not enjoying one
of the groups that you're in
it doesn't put a ton of pressure on you
to like have to get certain
results and things like that
for like any funding purposes.
But yeah, so I started off in
like a nuclear theory group
and then the next semester
I went into a biophysics lab
and then I realized, nope I
would much rather be a theorist.
So then I went back to what I knew I loved
and I joined the quantum
photonics applications group
which it was nice
and I chose it because they
have experimentalists in it
and they have theorists and
they have everything in between.
So I figured I could probably
just spend the rest of my time
in this group and try
out everything I want
to my heart's content (chuckles).
- Yeah, I'll just chime in and quickly add
that I think I had a pretty
similar experience to Emily
at least within the physics
department here at Yale
there is an informal rotation system
and so what I did was during
my first semester here
I actually just sort of worked informally
in a couple of groups
mainly just kind of
doing informal readings,
seeing what they were working on,
getting a sense for what
the research was like
and through that process,
I got a sense of maybe
which of the two groups
I was looking at seemed like
it would be a better fit for me
and then I started doing some
very, very basic low, you know
low time commitment research with them
during my first academic year.
Here at Yale it's, you know,
the first two years you teach
and so that's what supports
you during the academic years.
And so similar to, as
Emily said, then it's nice
because you don't have
to have the pressure
to be funded by your research group
during those first two academic years.
So you can, you know, put in
as much time as you're able
while also focusing on
teaching and classes.
And so it gives you a
little bit of a period
to try out some different research groups.
I should say that not all
programs work this way,
I think there are some
where you're funded
directly by research groups
or you can be as soon as you
sort of set foot in the program
so, you know, looking
at different programs
and trying to understand
the different funding models
is actually something
that can be important
and relevant to you
as someone potentially
considering graduate school
'cause that can definitely have
an impact on your experience
or more generally just the
the flexibility you might have
in exploring different groups.
- Yes, funding is the name of the game
and I'm gonna flash on my screen.
If you go on any of the
website of the grad school
usually you have a tab with the resources
and the first thing that pops in
is the funding and the grants
because, of course, you
need to get your fundings
there's no need of going to grad school
if it's to just crushing bone (laughing)
and then not having any money.
And one thing that's often
haze is the teaching.
You talk about, both of
them talked about that
then we have a question in the chat.
Somebody is interested
in hearing your thoughts
on the teaching side, how
much time does it take?
And do you wish it was more teaching,
less teaching, what's the balance is it...
Yeah, and so the person said that
teaching is not something
that he particularly enjoy,
oh, sorry, they particularly enjoy
and they are worried
it's gonna be a burden
like, can you give us the
the ratio of time to spend
preparing class and TA-ing?
- I think that really
depends on both the class
your TA-ing and where you're doing it.
I know that at the UoA you can be a grader
so if you don't enjoy
standing up in front of people
or like maybe you don't wanna
have those like interactions
like there is the option to be a grader
in which case you'd
never actually interact
with the students you just
interact with the professors.
That however is my least
favorite part of teaching
and I also saw I'm a slow grader
and I don't find it
rewarding at all (chuckles).
So I much prefer when I'm
teaching labs and discussions
but I know that in the
physics department at the UoA,
the time commitment
it varies so much depending on the class
because it'll be like, if
you're doing discussions
maybe you only really need to be there
for the discussion times
but then there's not much to
grade or prepare ahead of time.
And then, but if you're doing labs
you may have to like help set up,
and then grade the lab
reports or grade tests.
So I know that they emphasize
that you shouldn't be spending
more than 20 hours a week
on TA-ing because that's all
you're really getting paid for
is you get paid to be a part-time teacher
and then other part-time
you're this being a student
but I do know that it can be difficult
for some people to balance.
I would recommend that if
you get into your program
perhaps talk to some of the students there
and they'll have an idea of
like what are the classes
that would work best for you.
But I'll say, I really love TA-ing
because I always went to grad school
for like physics education research.
So now I'm funded through my research
so I don't need to TA,
but instead I'm trying to come up
with a nice outreach opportunities
so that I could still fulfill
that, like part of myself.
- Ann you were trying to say something?
- I was just gonna say
that it really depends both
the amount of teachings
whether it's 20 hours a
week or 10 hours a week
the kinds of courses, whether
you're leading a section
or whether you're doing grading
really will depend on the
school and the research group.
And so, you know
physics students may be asked
to teach a different amount
than computer science
students say at Yale.
So there's a great deal of variety.
I think one thing to know
is that at least at Yale
we have a training program
for first-time teachers.
So people who may say, oh my God
I don't know how, I can't
stand in front of a classroom,
I don't, you know, that isn't me,
there are a lot of tools to
help you become a better teacher
but I'd also say it also, you know,
depending upon what program you enter
some programs won't
allow students to teach
in their first year.
Some students start teaching
their very first year.
Really what you want to do
is, you know, do your homework
the nice thing is everything's on the web.
You can usually find out
when you go to the department
that you're thinking of joining
when the teaching is and at
what level and if they have,
usually you're not just
thrown out into the classroom
and asked to sink or swim,
usually there are people there
to help you learn how to do this well.
And you may find
that it's something that
you didn't think you liked
but then there's a particular
aspect you really like,
as Emily said that she loves
the interpersonal aspect,
but doesn't like the grading.
And you might find that
actually you find the grading
or even just being there
sometimes TAs are there
to help answer questions.
You know, sometimes you're
not actually leading a section
you may find
that one-on-one work is
something that you really enjoy.
So I think there are
various forms of teaching
and whatever program
and institution you're thinking of joining
you'd wanna ask about that
what does it look like
and what are the different
kinds of opportunities
available to you?
- It looks like somebody
asked if you're a TA
do you need to develop your
own curriculum for the class?
So I would say that's unlikely
I know at the UoA there's opportunities
to be at like a summer
course teacher, in which case
I assume you have more like
control over the curriculum
but I know that in my experience
it's been like the
worksheets and the lab books
and the labs and everything
is already set up
and then you'd mainly just like alter it
so that it like works for
your students in the room.
So like you would give an introduction
based off of what you think they know
or what they've learned from
you in the previous labs
and then maybe you realize
that you have a very slow group
so you might like take certain parts out
that are less important,
but that was my experience
so I think that's less that
you create the curriculum
and more of you to just kind
like apply it to the students.
- I would add
that I think that's
probably pretty typical.
I think most programs
know that not everyone
may be as interested
in doing a whole lot of teaching
or developing their own materials
and so they probably try to
minimize the amount of time
you would have to do that.
Certainly here at Yale, most
of the teaching assignments
are exactly the kind of
thing Emily described
but I will say on the flip side of that
if you're someone who is
interested in teaching,
I happen to also be very
interested in teaching
and I've tried to really
make it an important part
of my graduate school experience,
opportunities too, for instance,
design your own curriculum
can also be very exciting things
so those are some things I've sought out
and actually one aspect for me
of my graduate experience
that I've really enjoyed
is being in an environment
where there are a lot of
resources surrounding teaching
so you can get involved in
the teaching community here
more broadly,
learn about how to be a better
and more effective teacher.
And so, you know, whether
teaching is a plus
or minus for you,
I think it's certainly something
that's worth considering
when looking at different programs
and important to bear in mind
all of the different ways
that it might affect your experience.
For me, it's been a huge positive here.
I've joined Yale Center
for teaching and learning
helping to teach other new
graduate students how to teach
that's all something I've really enjoyed
but for other people
who don't like teaching
Yale's also been a nice
option as an example
because the required number
of teaching hours per week
is only 10 within the first two years.
So comparatively, I think
that's a fairly small number
but you know, all sorts
of different programs
are gonna have different pros and cons.
It's really gonna come
down to doing your research
and seeing how the particular program
might fit with your interest.
- [Florian] Go a head Russ
- I was just gonna chime in for a second.
So even though my background
is not related to quantum,
you know, going through grad school
I did a lot of teaching
of lab sections in geology
since that's what my degree
is in, and I loved it.
I loved teaching as a graduate student.
And I'm kind of speaking to the question,
developing your own curriculum
one of the ways that I actually got funded
was by helping develop the lab curriculum.
So it'll probably be
a little bit different
in engineering and physics
but there are those types of opportunities
where you can definitely
kind of shape the curriculum
if that's something you're interested in
but generally you're not expected to
just from my experience so.
- All right, that's good.
Thank you all.
So we have more-
- [Emily] (indistinct)
- Oh, go ahead.
Do you want to say something more?
- Sorry, I saw that something said
like, if you do enjoy teaching,
like what should you look for in a school
I was gonna say that if
you see that a school
has like a professor
who focuses on like
physics education research
or something like that,
that's probably going to be
like incentivize going there
because like you know
that they're gonna be
keeping up with research
and they're going to be like willing
to like actually study what's
going on in the classroom
whereas other schools
may just kind of have outdated materials
which I know can become
frustrating to have to teach
even if you enjoy teaching.
- One other quick detail on
this point, I just mentioned,
as many schools will also have centers
for teaching and learning
which could be a good
contact point for you.
If you are interested in teaching
they could tell you what
the experience is like
and resources you could find
if you wanted to further
explore that interest
but that's not a thing that's
present at all schools.
So if you are interested, you know
that would be a good sign
and a place you could find out more.
- And also, depending on what
you're gonna do with your PhD,
if you want to join industry,
teaching is not gonna be as important
as if you want to become a
professor and have your own group
because you would be
required to create curriculum
and so it really depends
on what's your career goal at the end.
So it's something that you might want...
I know that five to six, seven
years is like a long time
but you really need to come in with a plan
because you might struggle
to find the motivation
because it's a very long time
if you sort of don't know
what's the end goal is,
you should not really join a PhD program
just because you get to be
called a doctor at the end,
which is great, we love it,
but it's a lot of struggle.
And there's a ton of question in the chat
about stress and struggle
and also a lot about the funding.
Maybe we're gonna go
with the stress one first
so we don't end up on a note too bleak,
but it's true that a lot of grad students
have period of stress, some
difficult, some depression.
Is there any tools that the
grad school has in place
to help these kind of students?
- Sure, I'm happy to take that.
And then if Connor and Emily
want to speak from their
personal experience.
I think graduate school
is the best of times
and the worst of times (chuckles)
and I think it's exciting
because you're focusing
on exactly what you wanna think about
and spend your time thinking about
and you're with like-minded people
but there's a lot of pressure
to get things done in a timely fashion
research, sometimes hits a dead end,
there may be problems with an advisor
and then, you know all
kinds of life can interfere.
You can get sick.
I think when you're
looking at graduate schools
first of all, there are
two things to consider.
One is you should always feel
as though part of your
education is asking for help.
No one knows how to do graduate school
until they've done it.
So (chuckles) you just ask questions
there's no such thing as
a bad or a stupid question
and you could be asking them of faculty,
you can be asking them of your co-students
so there may be an older
student that you get to know
but never be afraid to say
I don't know where to go to do X
or I'm interested in X where
can I learn more about it?
Or I'm really struggling with
Y do you have any suggestions
about what I might do
or whom I might talk to?
And I can't speak to every institution
but I would say most institutions
have an office of student's life
who will help you think about, you know
how you bring together the intellectual
and the personal side of, you know
meeting people, issues with
housing, those kinds of things.
Many schools have really
amped up their mental health
and counseling and I think
stress is a big thing
but there're also wellness centers.
And so I think having a good sense
of when things are not going right for you
and not being shy about asking for help
and seeking counseling if you need it,
there's career services,
there's the center for
teaching and learning,
as Connor mentioned
there's a writing center at most places
so if you're struggling, you know,
to really put your ideas down on paper
that's a place to go.
And, you know
struggle can take any
number of different forms.
What I would say is almost every student
will have some challenge that they face
in the four to six years that
they're in graduate school.
And that's not a sign that
something's wrong with you
that's just a sign that it's hard.
And I think that your job
when you encounter a challenge
is to find the right resources
and if you don't know, just
ask as many people as you can
your Director of Graduate Studies
should be able to help you with this.
The Dean's office should be
able to help you with this.
So, you know, if you
don't know where to start
those are often good places to start.
There's no sort of magic formula,
but I think the main thing
is to know yourself
and know when you can't
handle something on your own.
I think graduate school is set
up for people to ask for help
that's why we have all these other offices
and no one expects students
to just magically know
how to do this.
You don't know how to write a dissertation
until you've written a
dissertation (laughing).
So I think the main thing is not to be shy
I would say the most successful students
take advantage of all the resources
that are available to them.
And I'm gonna stop there and
let Connor and Emily jump in.
- Before you do that
I also want to point out that
I've been through grad school
and that the pattern that I've seen so
is that you start very excited about it.
You're like you're brand
new students, it's very nice
and then your advisor can help you
because he has all the answer for now
because you still learn about the field.
And then you slowly realize
that you're gonna start
to research a topic
that you are the only one
or like one of the few in
the world who know the answer
and no Googling, no book,
no anything will help you
because you are like on
the verge of knowledge
and you're discovering new things.
And it's also a very distressing time
because you feel that you're on your own
and then this is what you need the help
of all your colleagues but also,
you need to sort of internalize
the fact that it's a hard job
and then you're gonna go through
this is not too difficult,
this is pretty good.
And one thing that really helped me
is to find a mentor that can help you.
Often, I realized that
the admin, so not the PI
but like people helping
either some associate Dean,
some manager in centers
and people like this
working with students
and doing programmings
are usually very helpful.
When I was doing my PhD in France,
we had one of the admin who
was sort of like my confidant
when something went wrong I
just went and ran onto him
and it was just talking
about it, really helped.
So that's something
that you should really
consider looking for mental
and asking for help, like Ann said.
Go on Emily
how stressful are you doing PhD (chuckles)
I at least could know,
now that you're don't, you
should look back and be like,
oh, that's nice
and Emily, I hope you're not
too stressed yet (laughing).
- For me, it definitely
like oscillates with stress.
Like I've been more
stressed out in grad school
than I've ever been before
but then also there's
just been lots of external
to grad school stressors that
are coinciding with, you know
trying to get my masters
and continuing the program
and things
so you just have to
like try to balance that
like, yes you want to get your PhD
but you also need to like,
live a balanced, healthy life.
And like the people,
you know, your advisors
and your peers and stuff
should be rooting for you
so do what you need to do to survive.
But there are certain like stressors
that I've seen 'cause like friends of mine
to choose to not to
continue with their PhD
and instead bust out of the program
and so I think those are
important to be aware of
so that you can maybe avoid them.
So some friends of mine maybe
would lose their funding
and that was the only group
that they were interested in being in.
And so like, it's hard to
do a lot of serious research
and TA and do everything, you know
all at the same time when
you're not getting funding
for all the research work you're doing.
So that's one thing is
like, it is good to know.
And I think it is okay to ask professors
if they have funding for
you, like ahead of time.
And like how many students
may be they're expecting
to take on in the future.
And then also asking
other graduate students
in the group questions like this.
So if you know there's a professor
you wanna work with, like
you can maybe ask them,
or you just directly email
students in the group
to see if they believe
that there's funding
but also if it's like a
pleasant work experience
because there's lots of really
talented people out there
who push their graduate students very hard
and they have very high expectations
and maybe that's not
something that you want
or like can withstand
because you are doing
other things in your life
and you are taking classes
and there are other responsibilities.
And then also just being aware of,
not only like the department
that you're going to be joining
but like the general area of your program
so like I've had friends
who moved here to Tucson
who then realized that
the Jewish community
isn't quite as large
as they'd like it to be
and that made their life very difficult.
And you know, maybe the UoA
doesn't take off certain
holidays that they do take off
so then they're not able
to like have all the tools
they think they need to
be happy on their own
let alone then to have
to endure the stresses
of the PhD program.
So like, it is important,
I'm not saying you should choose a school
based only off of the area it's in
but that can be an important factor
and if you are going to make
it through your program.
- I think the issues
that I'm hearing from you
and I think Connor raised
earlier are community.
So making sure you have
the kinds of communities
you're gonna need to thrive.
So if you're someone who's
very religious, you know
make sure that there's
a religious community
that is either on campus or off campus
that is gonna really be supporting you
during these years.
And communication which
Connor brought up earlier,
really trying to suss out
whether you are gonna get
on well with your advisor
and that you're gonna be able
to talk directly with them
about anything that arises
and whether it's a work-life balance
or taking the research
in a certain direction
someone you feel you're going
to be comfortable working with
that's one of the prime ways
that you can avoid problems downstream.
And sometimes that's tough
to tell when you're applying
I think sometimes you don't
know until you're there
but it's certainly something,
this is one of the reasons
why if there are only one or two people
at an institution that you
think you want to work with
you should be talking to
them before you even apply
to see whether their interpersonal style
and yours are gonna mesh.
- I'd add just one other
quick comment on this topic
maybe before we move on.
I wanted to actually to emphasize
some of the things that Ann
and Florian mentioned earlier
about the importance
of knowing what resources
are available to you
and asking for help when you need it
and so far as a mechanism
to fight off stress.
So for instance, in my own experience
and in many other graduate
students' experiences,
one challenging thing to
deal with in graduate school
can be imposters syndrome, as one example,
where you feel like, you know
maybe your research isn't exciting enough
or you're not doing well enough
or you're not smart enough
to be in the program
this kind of thing is it
can be a common sentiment.
And I think for me personally
this is something I struggled
with early on in the program
'cause I didn't realize all
the resources I had access to
I wasn't talking to the
older members in my group
to try and get help when
I was stuck on problems.
I wasn't, you know, leveraging
some of the other resources
that were available to me in my group
and others in the
Quantum Center and so on.
And so I do think, you know
I just wanted to emphasize
from personal experience
that knowing about the resources
that are available to you
and an understanding that
it is the expectation
that it takes time to learn
about a topic in a field
then it's okay to not know
things and ask questions
and you know, this is all important things
that everyone has to do at some point.
So for me, it took a while
to come to that realization
and that was stressful, but you know
having other people around
to help you through that
it can be a really important thing.
- Okay, we have a lot more
question about fundings.
So there's different way of funding.
So we talked about how
to get funding through TA
but there's also fellowship and anything.
Connor, you had fellowship with NSF
can you talk, tell us a little bit more,
what was the process and
how you got that one?
- Yeah, absolutely.
So most of my funding while
I was a graduate student
came through an NSF Graduate
Research Fellowship.
And so the way that worked was during,
it was actually my second
year of graduate school
I submitted an application during the fall
where I proposed the kind of research
I would be doing for my PhD
and there were other components as well.
And they came back
and offered me funding for
three more years after that.
So then in the subsequent three years
that is where my funding came from
so I didn't have to teach
and I also didn't have to ask my advisor
to provide me with support
out of one of their grants.
So the nice aspect of something like that
is that it can give you a
little bit more flexibility
to work on whatever it
is you're interested in.
So when you have your own
funding source, you can, you know
go to potential advisors and say, you know
I'm interested in this topic
can you work with me on this?
And they don't have to worry
about funding money from a
grant to help you with it.
So it can give you a little bit
more flexibility in that way
and so I think fellowships in that regard
can be a useful thing
certainly for you as a student.
- And you can apply for fellowships
either as an undergraduate
to use in graduate school
or while you're in graduate school.
Usually an undergrad institution
will have a fellowship's office
and so you can start with them.
And then often the graduate school
will have either an office or a site
where you can look for fellowships
that might be pertinent to you.
There are a number of, sort
of big name fellowships
that many people get like Fulbright's
which are to travel elsewhere.
And most campuses will have somebody
who can help you with that.
I'd also say that the writing center
can help you with applications
even if there isn't a fellowship office.
So there are a lot of different ways
that you can find funding.
But I wanna repeat that if you're applying
to say an R1 institution, like, Yale
you're going to get five years of funding.
You know, it may be that you
have to find a research group
that will accept you but I would say
there are very few instances I know of
where someone had to leave graduate school
because they had no funding.
So that's something to
just reassure people on.
You know, it's something
that you wanna be aware of
but chances are once you
have gotten into a program
if it's an R1, a Research 1 institution
unless you have a major
disagreement with the single person
who does research in your
area you should be okay.
- And there's also a lot
more initiative lately.
The US Government has created
this national quantum centers.
We have hubs everywhere
and so these centers
have a lot of fundings
and including the fundings
that they receive from the government
they have fellowships for
graduate students, for post-docs
and so you may be able to to
go check on these websites
there's also the national labs
are often associated with
these hubs, these quantum hubs
and so you may be able
to find different way
to have resources.
I think the easiest way is to
get paid by the grad school
so you don't have to write anything
so it's sort of like
be the "carefree thing"
it's not available to anybody
but those are also other options.
And also I know that sometimes
university can partner with industry
and the industry will pay
for a chunk of the funding
so that also happens.
That happened also a lot in Europe
there's some of these privates,
Government partnership
so that's also something
that you can consider
depending on where you
want to go for grad school.
So we're almost out of time.
I think maybe what we can do
is we can take one last question
talking about the timeline
of applying to grad school.
Like, what are the deadlines
and what are the time that we
need to take to go through?
- So I was just typing an
answer to that question
because it seemed like
one, what I would say
is our application at Yale opens in August
and depending upon the program,
the deadline can be
December 1st, December 15th
or January 1st.
And so if you are thinking of applying
you really wanna have
your materials ready.
I'm gonna try and fold in another question
which is what do you need to do to apply?
But let me talk about the timeline
and then I'll try and tell
you the biggest pieces
of getting ready to apply.
So then usually depending upon the program
there may be an on-campus
visit that is arranged
or a virtual visit,
and sometimes some schools do that
before acceptance decisions are made
and some schools do it
after decisions are made
and even that can vary within programs.
Usually in early spring,
January and February decisions are made
and then the students
who have been admitted
have to make a decision by April 15th.
So that's the rough
timeline, but I would say go
if you're thinking of specific schools
you should go and look
at the school's website
and they will have a
more specific timeline.
The things that you wanna
focus on in your application
are really research,
in the sciences that's the key issue.
And it's also the determining issue
for those who really
thrive in graduate school
in the sciences.
Faculty are looking for students
with prior research experience.
And you want in your statement of purpose
which is different from an
undergraduate personal statement,
to really answer questions
about why do you wanna
come to graduate school?
What are the questions or problems
that really interests you?
What have you done to
prepare to work on these?
And why is the institution
that you're planning to come to
or applying to the right
place for you to do this?
And that means knowing who the faculty are
and what kind of research
they're working on.
So the statement of purpose is really key
and prior research experience
is also really key.
I would say the third piece
that's really important
is letters of recommendation,
because those are the,
and you wanna get them as at
least three strong letters
from people who know your work,
have seen you do research
and know you as a person.
And I could say more about that
but I noticed the time and
I don't wanna keep anybody.
- Sounds good, but almost out of time,
maybe while I flash the
next events for the series
maybe we can go round
and have a last few words
from each of you and the last advice
that you can give people
considering grad school.
- Advice broadly for people
considering grad school
is a well, a very broad category.
So I don't know that I can say something
that's gonna be of
interest to everyone here.
But I think one thing that
for me was very helpful
in this process was just
speaking to students
at the different programs
I was looking at.
You know, a lot of the questions
I think have been posed here
are things that people who
have been through the program
can readily answer for you
and really speak to how it
affected their experience
whether these different factors
were positive or negatives.
And so, you know, I
think talking to students
as you look at different programs
should be a crucial determining factor
in gathering information.
So not only can you talk to people
about the structure of
the graduate program
or the department as a whole,
but you can also talk to people
in a particular research group
to get a sense of what it's like
to work with a particular advisor,
is the environment stressful,
what are the expectations on the students?
You know, I think this is all
information you can gather
before you accept or even
apply to certain programs
to try and whittle down your choices.
And so for me, at least
certainly this was really
valuable information.
And for those considering graduate school
I would say if you're on the
fence about different programs
or different areas of research
definitely talk to some
of the students there
they can certainly help point
you in the right direction.
- Yeah, I think that just,
even if you're embarrassed to
ask a question about something
like it's better to ask
and have someone hopefully
answer it for you.
So emailing professors that
you wanna work with them,
emailing like other people
who have positions in the
department, stuff like that,
that's a great way to gather information.
And even just like
directly emailing students
is a great way to get information.
Or if you can visit onsite,
like that's like walking around
and talking to people in
person, it's totally worth it.
But if you're emailing professors
and they aren't replying
do not take it personally
I know that lots of them just
have so many emails every day
and like I have a hard time
getting responses from my advisor
sometimes depending on how busy he is.
So if you're really interested
with working with someone in particular,
I would send follow-up
emails and things like that
without thinking you're bugging them
or thinking that they're ignoring you,
it's much more likely that it's just lost
in the stream of emails they get.
- So I would say don't be
afraid to aim high, you know
ask a lot of questions,
do your homework and your research
to find out who's doing what where
and don't be afraid to ask for help
at any stage along the way.
- I'll just echo what
everybody else has said.
It's really important to do your homework
in terms of, you know, or do
as much homework as you can
because once you make the choice, you know
you're kinda there and you
wanna make the best of it
and not have to switch
or anything like that.
So doing all your homework ahead of time
will really help with all that
and asking all those important questions.
- Perfect.
Thank you very much all of you,
thank you for all the attendees
who came in and asked the question.
This is will be recorded
and put later on on our websites.
So you'll be able to have
all the answers again
if you missed something.
Thank you all to our panelists
and have a good night.